It's reported at least 44 trans
people were murdered
in 2020 alone,
and despite your fears, you say
you feel a deep responsibility
to share your truth.
Why?
Well, you know, so much of
the privilege I have,
the ability to be here
sitting here right now
is really because of so many
trans women of color
who have consistently
put their lives on the line
throughout history, you know?
When we think of
Marsha P. Johnson or Miss Major.
I'm grateful to have the access
to the resources I've had
because I don't know what
would have happened if I didn't.
And there's so many people
in this community, like I said,
don't have access
to health care already
and then you have now in states
that are trying to ban
gender-affirming health care
for transgender youth,
and I guess I don't know how to
really say it
other than it just feels
more important
than feeling scared
in moments.
It feels more important than if
I have an overwhelming day.
It, to me, really simply feels
like absolutely
the right thing to do.
Who or what force helped you
to move through the fear?
Who did you lean on
or what did you lean on
to help you move
through the fear?
I'm surrounded by
really incredible people
who I work with
and just fully support me.
Friends who, you know,
fully support me
and are there for me.
And, um, and again,
being inspired by
so many people
who have a lot more courage
that I do and that, you know,
that love and support
and encouragement.
Was your mom-- was your mom
a big source of support?
Yeah, I mean, I-- I think as I
talked in the "Time" article,
obviously in my childhood
and things were, you know,
a bit different,
but my mom can't be, you know,
couldn't be more supportive
and such an advocate
for the LGBTQ+ community.
So thrilled for me and that
I'm in this place in my life.